[SPEAKER_01]: Third of Wealsun, Merrick has just come into the barracks and heard the end of Folsom's disastrous song.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're shocked.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not too happy right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because this is exactly what you were told to avoid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge takes Folsom outside and you're a little worried he's gonna stab the kid and throw him in a...
[SPEAKER_01]: Me too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Throw him in an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you see Owen Black up against the bar going, laughing and drinking right next to Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, what happened to Folsom?
[SPEAKER_01]: That must have been rough on our whole mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a farce.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was meant to be a farce, a joke.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kid always tries to crack jokes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I keep telling him.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not working.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you should tell him Marines don't like jokes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially not when it's about them.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what Marines like?
[SPEAKER_02]: Beer!
[SPEAKER_00]: And put my gold on the table there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kevin looks like I came in at a wrong time.
[SPEAKER_00]: That song, was that for In My Favor?
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys put that on for me when I came in?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you talk to him at all?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so, I'm gonna see you later, buddy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good to see you, Owen.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll talk to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we all owe a full small word after this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I gotta talk, I gotta report to my captain, so...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm bailing from the bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was that Gouge in the bar?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have no idea who that guy was.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why'd you let him take your friend out?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll see you later.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm out the bar.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm out the door.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I don't know what Gouge is going to be.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you're going to leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll talk to Owen for a second.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you go, and they'll talk.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was a show.
[SPEAKER_00]: Strange circumstances.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good to see you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hope your travels have been good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good to see you in one piece as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, you know, how's it been?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stay busy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just got back from Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Made quite a haul.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where all the merchants have been stuck by the Duke of Gradsall, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was able to load up the skiff, make it back with quite a bit of food.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have a drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's full.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not watered-down ale or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_00]: Care if I join you for a drink really quick?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll buy you one.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd be all free anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_00]: After a performance like that, I think I need to clear my mind a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Red Shore, you say?
[SPEAKER_00]: Busy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, 50 merchant ships there.
[SPEAKER_01]: They can't unload them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't have the docks for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've been to Red Shore, you know what it looks like.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a whaling town.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a hard time unloading ships, I mean, fishing ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: But merchant ships, they can't do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're all there languishing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Full of food that's rotting, full of goods that are not being sold.
[SPEAKER_01]: Duke of Gradsul is making a mess of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sounds like it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But my profit, to my profit, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: When did you get back from, what did you say, Red Farm?
[SPEAKER_01]: Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, when did you get back from Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_01]: Today.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just got back today?
[SPEAKER_01]: Noon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: I talked to Tyrus about the sahaugin that were in the bay, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: A couple of them attacked us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you seen Sahaugin all the way out there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I was five miles from the city, that's when they attacked us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg or Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've seen Sahaugin, though, on the coast of Selenmore, up near Red Shore.
[SPEAKER_00]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think some of my men have been running in Sahaugin as well, which is very unlike.
[SPEAKER_00]: We haven't seen them in years.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're coming back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, something strange is going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any of your men?
[SPEAKER_00]: Get hurt on the way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two died.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sahaugin?
[SPEAKER_00]: It was the Sahaugin, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any other trouble besides the Sahaugin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm almost as good as a pilot as you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was able to avoid the patrols.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: I trust your navigational skills are probably traveling a lot more lately.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably increasing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I think the only other person that can make it through the patrols and get to Red Shore besides me is you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: We both know this.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think about going into business?
[SPEAKER_01]: Quitting this foolishness in the Marines?
[SPEAKER_00]: The city needs ya.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: And politics are getting a little old around here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not sure what's going on, per se.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, according to your friend over there, the princes are all fools.
[SPEAKER_00]: According to him, the princes are all fools.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not here to make any negotiating answers.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm here to have a drink and catch up with my cousin and apparently get mocked to by some bard.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yes, Owen, that was Gouch who was here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You think you can get him on your crew?
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouch, for the right coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or the right amount of red-eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: He'd be very useful out there on the sea if he wanted that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He would.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was thinking about hiring him myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know him by reputation, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, about a week ago, I took a compatriot of his, this elf, from Red Shore to Essar.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a small fishing town on the north coast of the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell them to get me in touch with Gouch.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think if we hire these mercenaries, we can do well for ourselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is true.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's dangerous out there, but... What are you smuggling nowadays?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your... Well, food seems to be the most important thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: As I would think.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, you know, that could be drawn in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sahaugin, too, if they smell stuff they're transporting, too.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, Owen, you have me intrigued, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: And, you know, I always have your best interests in mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, go say that, boy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm out for.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm afraid Gouge is gonna kill him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to make sure Gouge doesn't do anything out of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Proposition him, though, and I can get you another boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can do this right, and we can make a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds good, Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.